the focus might be on the football but
in the meantime there's the cold to deal
with temperatures plunging across the
country the Met Office issuing warnings
for snow and ice
our weather is highly variable depending
on which way the wind is coming from and
through the Autumn we head Westerly or
southwesterly winds throughout those
three months of the Autumn and that
brought mild but often wet and windy
weather now the winds have suddenly
switched to come from the north and
Northern winds at this time of year in
particular are going to be cold
there is already disruption Manchester
Airport temporarily closing both runways
due to heavy snow with dozens of flights
canceled
and as well as the health impacts
weather is piling more pressure on
people dealing with the cost of living
crisis
Shoppers at this Christmas Market in
York worried about the cost of heating
their homes and they have much less
money to spend we're still very worried
about it because there's other things
isn't there that have gone up in price I
have mine on timer but if I go out of an
evening I'll switch to the timer off and
then I'll put it back on again when I
come in working from home we've normally
have it on during the day but
we don't have it on during the day we
just have it on at night time now just a
little bit just to take the chill off
for vulnerable people it is even harder
as staff at this women's refuge in
central London know we're definitely
seeing an increase in women coming in
who are either rough sleeping or even
women who have somewhere to stay but
they can't afford to heat it and so they
come to us for a place of warmth and
hospitality
unfortunately the cold snap isn't ending
soon
these temperatures are likely to
continue until at least early next week
but forecasters also say that it could
keep feeling cold or very cold with
temperatures mainly below average all
the way up until Christmas
and the colder it gets the more energy
we will use adding to concerns about
Supply matching demand the last thing
anyone needs in these conditions is
blackouts
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News